throughout the omicron fueled fifth wave
saskatchewan has been an outlier there
were no gathering limits over christmas
and when the break ended students
returned to school in person as
scheduled but even as hospital numbers
in the province begin to once again rise
the premier is steadfast with his
approach as we
look at at you know public health
restrictions that would be put in place
that ultimately would limit
you know people from from coming
together whether that be in schools
whether that be in workplaces in our
community
there it doesn't seem to be slowing the
spread of omicron in other areas of
canada gathering restrictions the
premier argued wednesday don't seem to
work i actually don't know
what
empirical data that he has
to
back up that claim but this
epidemiologist worries saskatchewan is
once again heading for trouble while the
number of patients in intensive care
units have fallen in recent weeks
non-icu patient numbers are on the rise
so we are about halfway through
into this into this wave
we are seeing 125 hospital beds occupied
and i think it could easily be doubling
and tripling you know from from that
point on the virus spreading so quickly
the premier himself announced thursday
he tested positive as well this is the
highest number of active cases that we
have identified in alberta at any time
during kovitt with more than 60 thousand
active cases alberta is also now seeing
hospital numbers rise but with pcr tests
now unavailable to most people with
symptoms and rapid tests impossible to
find the actual case count in the
province is likely much higher with more
still to come we're not even
seeing the cases that were caused by the
gatherings at christmas or
new year's yet so the odds are things
are going to get significantly worse but
like scott moe jason kenny is resisting
calls to implement new restrictions
hoping instead that the omicron wave
will peak and fade away before hospitals
become overwhelmed heather urex west
global news calgary